[Music]
it's a Monday PFT ot some things we
weren't able to get to during two hours
of talking playoff games and browns
hiring another head coach Chris Sims
Mike Florio here with you we made it
back from California I didn't get a
chance to thank you for this during the
show let me thank you now and I want to
say a very heartfelt and very sincere
thanks for all the support you've
provided to me while I was being heckled
by 49ers fans on the sidelines you know
you egg them on yes you riled them up
yes
that's what I do baby that's what I do
you know Brandon Stokley when I used to
play on the the Broncos he used to call
me the shit-stirrer cuz you know I'd
always go in the locker room and do
stuff like that so I love that I thrive
on that and that was great yes I look
like I'm the awesome 49ers guy you look
like you're the the jerk Vikings guy and
yeah I wanted to egg it on a little bit
who it was that was fun
that was a lot of fun you were doing the
skull clap with those giant bird wings
you call arms and and you were you were
pointing at me and laughing but here's
the thing it was funny because there was
a level of malice that was coming from
them originally right I don't care like
what are you gonna do come across well
maybe they could have but I didn't care
and I wasn't all I was doing was smiling
giving him the thumbs up but when you
started doing that it kind of took the
it took the edge off right yeah yeah it
was it was no longer an angry middle
finger it was a jovial middle face right
yeah usually flash yes exactly it was
they became more of a yeah sometimes you
got to confront those things to take the
mean spirit away and just like remind
everybody hey this is sports this is a
human being he likes the Vikings yes
he's an idiot
but let's not eviscerate him okay yeah I
just wanted to make sure they knew that
by you so so thank you for stirring and
also thank you for taking a little of
the temperature out of the situation all
right on Sunday night we saw the
Seahawks and the Eagles the Eagles but
the Seahawks and the Packers play due to
being cloudy who was a very
controversial figure in the Seahawks
Eagles game CR recovered there he's done
now free agent
he can go anywhere he wants and he said
after the game he wants to play for a
contender he doesn't care about money he
doesn't want money he wants to play for
a good team I just want to win I want to
get to that Super Bowl by any means I'm
not looking to get on no sorry team for
money that ain't gonna fly where do you
think clown he's gonna be next year well
I don't I mean I don't think there's a
good big chance he ends up in Seattle
this is what I love about Jujubee on
clowny though he's a real competitor a
real football player I've never heard
anything other than that you could tell
winning is important to him he's not
into like oh I need sax and sexiness I
don't give a damn what his stats are he
was the best player on the Seahawks
defense went healthy there's no doubt
about that and that's the big thing to
me with Jadeveon Clowney is he's got to
get his health right you know he's a guy
that you know is just he fights a lot of
injuries every year I feel like it and
he's a phenomenal football player there
will be a demand for him because he is
the master of f the play up where he
ends up I don't know but I think he just
narrowed the list down pretty hard
pretty strong there where he's gonna go
to a team that he feels like is you know
in that conversation and he will make a
difference for a team whatever it is but
I have you made me bet Mike I would
think he doesn't get out of Seattle I
know one place he won't end up most
likely and that's Philadelphia as a
result of yeah hit on Carson Wentz the
aftermath of it when he said the Eagles
fans are the worst in the league and it
remember when the trade talk was
happening back in August and September
the Eagles were one of the tween oh that
was mentioned they're gonna be off the
list I think when the free agency tour
begins
well they you know I think they could
forgive very easily once they saw a guy
like that come into town and and you
know one and realize that this is not a
mean like guy that has malice in his
eyes or anything like that this is a guy
who loves playing football he plays it
hard you know I've never got the
impression he's dirty by any stretch of
the imagination and you know it is gonna
be interesting
you know who is it I'm because now I'm
pulling up salary caps just to look at
for like next year you know like just
things like hey the Buffalo Bills they
got a lot of money they need a
difference-maker on their four
seven that's for sure I look at them the
Dolphins they're a team up there the
Colts who have all their money they need
a difference-maker there's gonna be a
market for him but yeah what is he gonna
do off slash Super Bowl contender and
where is he gonna deem we're okay that's
not worth it and I'll take a little less
to go play for a contender I think
that'll be the interesting thing in this
combo yeah and I think a lot of it
depends upon how this season ends and
the thing is the best teams have their
pass rush taken care of it's gonna be
looking for a team that has a really
good offense that needs an extra kick in
the ass
that's right through that defense it
doesn't already have money tied up or
the future tied up through someone they
drafted you know like the 49ers they
wouldn't have a spot for Mature he'd
love to play for the 49ers
they're not gonna have that opportunity
but there will be demand the one caveat
though his injury yeah right let's had
injuries throughout his career he had
that sports hernia that kept him from
being at his peak for the final two
months of the season and we thought it
flared up last night it turned out that
he merely was hit as Chris Myers of Fox
said in the family jewels I was good
rather than he was back in the game yeah
that was that was that was funny but I
thought I thought that that thing had
finally like something that finally
happened with the sports hernia right
done ya know if the field he was clearly
in pain it turned out he just got kicked
in the in the groin area yeah speaking
of groins and hamstrings and other
assorted injuries will fuller the Texans
receiver vows to be able and available
to play all 16 regular season games next
year Chris has been one of your pet
peeves ever since I've known you the
idea that a guy keeps having the same
injury and maybe the training staff and
the medical staff isn't treating what
may be the deeper problem and then you
figure out what the deeper problem is
and get it fixed with one full or
they're never gonna get the most out of
him that that's right I mean he's first
off you heard Tony Romo yesterday during
the game right they're a different team
we've been we've been banging that drum
for the last 10 weeks right I mean
they're not the same when he's not in
there when he is in there they're one of
the most explosive offenses in football
so he's got to do something and yes you
know when you've got hamstring issues
for five years now there's it's
something more than the hamstring the
hamstring pulling is the symptom it's
not the root of the problem I've learn
a lot about this stuff when I lost my
spleen I had all my core issues
everything like that he's got to go find
a muscle specialist he's got to go find
somebody to test all his muscles to make
sure they're firing up to capacity you
know just my little two cents yeah you
know hey we're gonna treat the hamstring
treat the hamstring his hamstrings
probably the strongest damn thing in the
world there's another issue that's why
we're keep pulling I don't know what
that is but he's got to go find those
answers not only for himself and his own
future and financial security but if the
Houston Texans want to rely on them they
need him to be healthy yeah and you're
right a different team when he's on the
field and and the deeper issue that a
lot of players have and and Chris look I
don't know the first thing about the
medicine up at the training aspects of
it I always thought it was very advanced
and the best stuff available was
available to NFL teams your experience
is that it's anything but and some of
these guys the only way they're gonna
get their problems fixed is to do it on
their own and find somebody apart from a
team that can get them the best possible
treatment and care and evaluation that
they need to get to 100% consistently
that's right you know this is where it
gets lost in translation NFL teams have
great surgeons at their behest right
they're got all that kind of stuff but
as far as physical rehab like issues
like that there's still years behind and
that's why you see a lot of the top
level players and the guys who have the
money right to be able to spend on the
on themselves and the offseason and
spend that extra whatever it is hundred
grand to Britain you know get their body
going yes because a lot of these great
rehab specialists physical trainer
physical therapy type guys they don't
the gray ones don't want to go work for
an NFL franchise they can work far less
hours and have to deal with far less
bull crap and far less players and
charge more per hour to have their own
practices so that's where people gotta
realize you know great surgeons
available because those doctors are you
know they want to be a part of the team
too but as far as physical rehab guys
that know stuff about the muscular body
stone-age they're 20 30 years behind
still and he's got to find the right
guys all right
next up the Minnesota Vikings have
plenty of decisions that they need to
make in the coming offseason one is what
to do with defensive end Everson Griffin
because he had more than six sacks this
season his contract is voided he becomes
a free agent and he can go anywhere he
wants he said he wants to stay with the
Vikings he's been a heart and soul of
that team for a lot of years and the
Vikings kind of stood by him when he had
an issue back in the 2018 season he was
gone for the team for a while I think he
very much would like to continue to be
part of it they've got some good young
pass rushers daniil hunter has kind of
taken over as the top guy there over the
past couple of years but but I'd like to
think that the Griffin and the Vikings
can find a way to keep working together
because he really is a key leader on
that team Chris well yeah he is and then
you know the scheme they play too
you know they want yeah they're they're
predicated on their defensive ends
getting pressure like that doing all
those type of things now I think the
thing they need to balance you know what
we're trying to look real quick what his
sacs were I mean he was right around 10
I'm just one two three four I got a four
and a half I'm gonna carry the one yeah
so he was under ten sacks of the year he
had eight sacks he had sex
so does this ask me I don't know what
you were doing I says that worth the
money Mike I mean I ask you he is a good
player he's a good leader is he a
superstar at this point in his career
anymore no is he worth 13 million a year
yeah it's--that's-- close one it's
debatable so I'd be interested to see
where they go cuz he's getting up there
in age and maybe they want to get
younger I think that'd be an interesting
decision for your Vikings team that has
cap issues I mean they have cap issues
you look at look at that right now
you're your team's probably in a worse
spot than any other team in football
right now well and they're gonna have to
do something to create some cap space
even that if that means extending Kirk
Cousins contract and and that's gonna be
a challenge for them to figure out the
right value if that opportunity arises
mike Zimmer's contract expires after the
season he said during the end of season
press conference on monday morning he
expects to have discussions about a
contract extension in the offseason I
mean the Vikings either need to to move
on from him or extend him I don't like
the idea
Zimmer and GM Rick Spielman being in
this lame-duck scenario especially with
some of these big picture decisions they
need to make and one of the first ones
will be can they fit Everson Griffin
under the salary cap and can they create
the cap space necessary to to keep their
younger players but it feels like they
always have a pipeline of very good pass
rushers in Minnesota a B that unless
Griffin wants to take a lot less then he
could get elsewhere assuming the offers
are there it's gonna be difficult for
him to stay with the Vikings for another
season all right a guy who was with the
Vikings and he used that as a
springboard to become a head coach for
the second time Pat Shermer after being
fired by the Giants now set to be the
offensive coordinator of the Denver
Broncos working with Vic Fangio
developing drew Locke your thoughts on
Shermer to denver i I really like this I
do you know first off I like schirmer's
offense it has everything you want about
it and he's gonna have not only you know
some young stars at his behest they're
you know with Drew lock Phillip Lindsey
know a fan Cortlandt sudden they got
some guys there you go that's a good
little nucleus
you know the offensive lines headed in
the right direction you got a Mike
Munchak as your offensive line coach
that's a pretty impressive staff and now
you got a coach you yes
knows how to dial up plays to be
aggressive in the pass game but likes to
run the ball and we'll do play-action
pass off that I think this this scheme
fits more of how Vic Fangio wants to
play as far as just a full team is
considered and I like this higher I like
tot Shermer the OC didn't love him as a
head coach but I like the OC hey Norv
Turner Wade Phillips Hugh Jackson guys
who are so good as coordinators they
keep getting opportunities to fail as
head coaches the sooner you accept this
is my role this is what I do I'm not
going to have the aspiration to have the
top job I can make a good living and I
can be very successful and maybe get a
Super Bowl ring or two as a coordinator
I think that's the way to go and I think
Pat Shermer is now at 9:23 with the
Browns 9 and 23 with the Giants I think
he needs to accept the fact that he
destiny is to be an offensive
coordinator all right last one
speaking of offensive coordinators the
Rams have won in Kevin O'Connell out
from Washington in to work with Jared
Goff as they try to to fix what went
wrong in in 2019 you know it's funny
Kristen the Rams are a very glass
half-full type of an organization I
think that's Shawn McVeigh's personality
always saying the right thing yeah doing
the right thing but the deeper concerns
are there Wade Phillips is out as
defensive coordinator and now they're
turning to O'Connell in the hopes that
he can get more out of Jared Goff
because last year obviously they didn't
get enough no you're right and I think
Shawn McVeigh you know this is a guy
that O'Connell has you know experienced
in the similar offenses McVeigh you know
being there under Jay Gruden of things
like that I also think Shawn McVeigh
looks at it and goes this guy can bring
some new fresh ideas to the offense too
and we collette can collaborate it takes
a little off of Shawn mcveigh's played
as far as always being worried about the
nuts and bolts of the offensive game
planning in a week-to-week basis now he
knows this guy can do that and then he
can tinker with oh maybe I'll bring you
know these 820 plays whatever 1020 plays
to the table just refers them creative
like up your plays every week and add
them to division him and O'Connell see
so I think this is a smart move takes a
little something off a McVeigh's plate I
think gets a guy in there to get fresh
ideas I still stand by you know McVeigh
and that Rams offense need to expand and
be a little more versatile and he needs
to continue to push the envelope and
reinvent himself and stop being in so
many one back one tight end three wide
receiver sets change it up that way and
I think O'Connell will go a long way to
helping them make that transition and
and freshen some things up there with
that offense yeah a lot for the Rams to
fix as they try to stay competitive in
the toughest division right now in
football especially if the Cardinals get
some help around Kyler Murray right
Seahawks are still going to be very good
yeah and the 49 is it looks like the
49ers are yeah they're they're putting
they're putting together another run
like the old glory days
that or did you go into the Hall of Fame
there the museum is on Friday and it is
awesome awesome Stadium music it then
the museum with all of the life-size
sculptures of the members of their Hall
of Fame whether it's ronnie Lott Steve
Young Bill Walsh Joe Montana those are
awesome I tell you the Ronnie Lott
statue can kick my ass well of course
Han yeah yeah I bet I know it's a low
bar I know it's a little bar but you can
get up in there and you can take a
picture and get right in the face or not
in glass or anything you walk around the
room and the statues are there it is
awesome and it's like every room has a
different vibe to it some are kind of
dark some are bright and they got all
the Super Bowl trophies it is awesome
awesome space they did a great job with
it it's a great Stadium I really love it
I've been there a few times it's it's
clean its new of course it's really well
designed it's got a great atmosphere as
we saw a lot of people were questioning
it and it's the real deal I would really
like to know what was louder for Kirk
Cousins the Super Dome with New Orleans
or San Francisco I know in the Superdome
in New Orleans he didn't use the silent
count he did when he was playing the
other night the other day against San
Francisco so I think that says something
there too and I think you know hey go
start giving that fan base a little
credit that that team's got a lot of
history we know but hey listen fan base
it's a rabid fan base when they're
winning and that's true of any fan base
Chris when they weren't winning they
weren't there and that's true of most
fan bases I can't name many where if
you're not winning they're not gonna be
there but but yeah look when they're
winning I'll agree with you there is
rabbit as anyone well just because
they're not showing up to the game that
you know that temor has to do with yet
that the stadium is in a weird spot it's
not in San Francisco so that changes
things like that yeah and you know yes
they weren't not winning
I mean before Shanahan got there and you
know up to last year you know there was
a disaster there I mean it was an
absolute disaster in that Tomsula and
Chip Kelly era they're so they're
they're getting things going I think
yeah I mean like you said they got it
set up right now
to where it looks like 49ers are gonna
be hanging around the top of the NFL for
at least the next four to five years for
sure they they got too much young talent
and studs and of course a young head
coach that got it all going in the right
direction and I'm not faulting them for
checking out after you have a history a
you have a history of excellence right
and then all of a sudden it turns to
crap yeah I wouldn't want to be part of
that either
right but but my point is let's not act
like this is the greatest fan base in
sports that will stick through you
through thick and thin I can't think of
a fan base that will stick with you
through the thin is that is the Packers
I don't know they haven't had much thin
but I don't remember a whole lot of
empty seats back in all those years the
Packers were or horrible but they man
it's a good question to take up another
day is there really a fan base out there
that would tolerate multiple years of
losing losing losing losing the way the
49ers did and it was bleak it was they
were talking about trying to fire the
owner that's how bleak it was yeah so um
anyway I I feel I feel bad now for
crapping on the 49ers for nice to know
after they were so nice to me on
Saturday and showed me their favorite
fingers on each hand yes yep you mean
this one yeah thanks don't move it
around I know I can't listen to blur it
alright that's it we'll see you tomorrow
with another edition of PFT live it's
championship week four teams left we'll
be spending a lot of time this week
getting you ready for the games to come
enjoy your Monday talk to you tomorrow
Thea
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports